i think of when i hear that again the
word pragmatism comes up because you're
talking about well what's the use of it
what's the point of it
so then i'm wondering well is
is reality or theorizing tied to
pragmatism in some sense yes because
we're finite beings we have to choose to
do something but then
can we not philosophize for the sake of
philosophizing so that's what occurs to
me and then at the same time when saying
well we don't know if these chinese
dragons are playing football in some
other dimension that never interacts
with us
however i would say it's still firstly
it's fun to think about chinese football
playing dragons and second
just like we were talking about in the
beginning
scientists have an aversion or generally
now contemporary scientists have an
aversion to philosophizing
they would say well this is much of what
you're talking about especially when it
comes to metaphysics is unfalsifiable
science is a methodology let's apply
that let's stick to our mathematics but
then you were making the great argument
which is
that leads us to plenty of places even
if it seems misleading at first or even
if it seems to not interact with us
first
so that's what else i think about it is
that okay even if we say there are these
non-interacting
chinese
dragons that play football
okay let me hear you out do you truly
believe that do you have some
great arguments for it let's hear it
okay let's think about that would this
be the case of that and then you can
arrive someplace interesting so i'd say
first you said it's about a point what
is the point what is the use then i say
well that's pragmatist that's pragmatism
in this sense of it has to have a use to
us and i'm saying well we could talk
about that but then also at the same
time there could be a use in the sense
that well we can talk about
incomprehensible unfalsifiable notions
and still lead us somewhere propitious
in the long run okay so that's what i
think now i say that and i'm curious
what are your thoughts on what i've just
said
well um
i wouldn't not disagree with you um
i think there is a
tradition in philosophy
so let me develop something i hinted
before there's a tradition in philosophy
which is to warn
philosophy as a cure witkinstein is a
master of that cure against wrong
questions
uh
we're wrong what does wrong mean here
uh you probably call me a pragmatist if
you say wrong means useless
so
uh
like not good for us ultimately leads us
astray but as humans
um
yeah so just
take us to the wrong
to to the wrong
if if you stay in science science was
often liberated
uh by philosophical thinking
that science often made step ahead
by getting input from philosophy that
said well you don't you don't have to
ask this question um
certainly
this later
copernicus but played a bigger role in
einstein einstein got from mach the idea
that
uh the asking the question of uh uh what
it's really really meaning of two things
happening at the same time it's just a
wrong question we forget about that
that's not
meaningful i mean
and
also from mac heisenberg
took the idea that
the electron doesn't have a position at
any time
directly from this is a this is a wrong
you you you're imposing a
so there is a there's a tradition in
philosophy which is warning
against the wrong kind of questions and
uh
i i think what i'm saying here what i'm
trying to say here is that uh
um
it's uh
the notion of reality is good uh because
we we use it to distinguish the the
chair in the mirror from the chair
um on which i can see it to distinguish
the dream from the
from what i see when i'm awake for
disclaimer what is what's in a play or
in a novel from what is not in a play in
a novel
or for distinguished i mean you tell me
that yesterday you met
john and say is that real or false
you lie that's this is meaningful this
is uh we know exactly what you mean by
real and false here
um
but then if we take this notion of real
and we make it uh uh
extrapolated
to say everything we see is not real
uh
because everything we see
uh
has a level of illusion of some kind
much weaker kind of the mirror much
weaker kind
uh
it's good that we realize that there's a
level of illusion but then we are
postulating that there is a
underlying reality
behind that
and that postulation might be
wrong
simply wrong or at least
it's let's put it this way it's
remarkable that science failed to get to
that ultimate reality so far so why
should we expect it wait what is the
multiple reality i mean
quantum fields i mean we don't even
know exactly what is a quantum field
because of the complication of quantum
mechanics we know it's a classical field
um
quantum field is something that
manifests itself with particles
okay but the particles are not real
so we are confused on the ultimate
reality even in contemporary physics
in contemporary physics today
not to mention about in philosophy in
general what is ultimate reality matter
energy god spirits language
everybody came out with a with an
ultimate reality story
and and failed to convince the others
um
so
the perspective i find it
uh interesting is to
de-emphasize
the notion of ultimate reality
and interesting interesting interesting
and use the word reality at level by
level i mean
that there's a chair there but he's also
real
that that chair is as some illusory
thing it's also real there's just a
bunch of atoms both things are true
and and within each context something is
real something
it's also and we can add content at
levels in which is a better
understanding of reality
uh without getting trapped into oh my
god we don't have access to reality we
don't have access to reality that's the
chair
okay i'll explain my thoughts what
occurs to me and then we can get the
rapid fire questions and answers just
from the audience because you've been so
generous with your time thank you
is that cool
absolutely okay
this has been a very philosophical
uh little physics little loop quantum
gravity lipogrip this is very very good
i guess
basic philosophy of science and physics
understanding and
the nature of reality
let me recapitulate what you said so i
make sure that we're on the same page
there are different ways that we use the
word reality just like there are
different ways we use the word time and
just like there are different ways we
use the word almost any noun essentially
depending on the context so let's
imagine we can put these contexts in
separate boxes much of the confusion
occurs when we think
well we
mean
well much of much of miscommunication is
we intend it to be from box a but you
perceive it as from being from box b so
the contexts are mixed up and what i was
wondering is when it comes to reality
even within the same context
i don't see there being an internally
consistent even within the context and
by the way you mentioned wittgenstein
wittgenstein had this notion of language
games i believe the language games would
be the equivalent of
context here boxes
i'm wondering if there's an internally
in an internally consistent notion of
reality
okay so
well and then where was i going with
that ah okay now my
what i think is at least i haven't seen
any and anytime i try to come up with
well i haven't seen any internally
consistent definition of reality
now there are a couple answers to that
one is
the donald hoffman method
forget it so it's there's no reality
it's all unreal in some sense then
there's the phenomenological answer the
phenomenology answer which is actually
all you experience is real it's real to
you even if you're schizophrenic and you
see a snake in front of you that's real
to you
but then you actually took a different
route which i never occurred which is
please stop using the word reality just
let's forget about it so am i making a
correct summary and if i'm in yeah just
correct yes yes yes yes yes uh please
stop uh using the word reality uh
unlabeled and uh
divorce the
reality i mean use use the word reality
in each context
so
it's like we should have reality sub a
reality sub b and make sure that we're
in
in this movie this is real this is real
this is false
but that's a movie it's all false in in
in a different sense of real so the the
the
realize
there's a variety of meaning with in the
context in which you
uh
in which you you use it so in a context
we
give you a context and i
i give you a much better definition of
reality okay
in the context of the miserable written
by victor lugo i can absolutely uh
uniquely see what is real and what is
not real what is real is what is written
in the book it's not real is what you
add it's not written the book okay in
the context of the history of the united
states
it's absolutely real
maybe
when we can make a mistake but we know
that to make a mistake so we know what
is real was not real that you know
george washington
announces becoming a king whatever
whatever happens
um
so
context by context we have a
with a clean notion of of reality which
allows us to make distinction
um
[Music]
between real things and not real things
it's a unique
word real reality to reality real not
real outside all context
which i think is dangerous